Speaker 1: One of the most anticipated debates
in the 2022 election cycle was last night.
It was quack television, Dr. Mehmet Oz against
Democratic Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman.
They are vying to be the next senator from
Pennsylvania.
Now, I am not going to sugarcoat this for
anybody.
And I didn't during yesterday's much watched
live stream.
John Fetterman suffered a stroke some months
ago.
He is recovering and has been cleared by his
doctors to say you can serve as senator.
He is not struggling cognitively in the sense
of memory, logic, critical thinking.
But Fetterman is struggling significantly
when it comes to speaking and translating
thought into speech.
It's really sad to see.
And what is horrifying is that the completely
unqualified, delusional and incompetent Mehmet
Oz.
May become a senator because John Fetterman
had a stroke.
And didn't perform particularly well last
night.
It was difficult to watch.
I'm putting politics aside here for a second.
I feel terribly for John Fetterman.
A public figure in the middle of a campaign
has a stroke running for an important office
and now visibly struggles to speak.
Needed closed captioning during yesterday's
debate in order to better understand the subject
matter having having trouble with order to
auditory processing.
I hope for the absolute best for letterman's
recovery.
And it was a very difficult debate to watch
last night.
By the way, Fetterman was not a particularly
good debater.
I mean, Fetterman was the best candidate in
the Democratic primary.
But even at the Democratic primary debates,
he wasn't the best debater.
Let's look at a few clips from last night.
The most disturbing clip was when Mehmet Oz
said that local political leaders should be
the ones making decisions, along with patients
and doctors about abortion.
No, they shouldn't.
It should be doctors and patients.
But here is Oz with a very extreme statement.
Speaker 2: There should not be involvement
from the federal government in how states
decide their abortion decisions.
As a physician, I've been in the room when
there's some difficult conversations happening.
I don't want the federal government involved
with that at all.
I want women, doctors, local political leaders
letting the democracy that always allowed
our nation to thrive, to put the best ideas
forward.
Speaker 1: So why do we need politicians in
the room?
Why is it better if they're local?
This idea of let the states decide when there
really aren't differences.
Let me give you an example.
When it comes to gun safety, as an example,
Bernie Sanders is correct that gun ownership
in Vermont is a very different thing socio
culturally than it is in, I don't know, North
Carolina.
And so.
Regardless of your views, I can understand
why one would say, Well, because gun ownership
in Vermont is a different thing than in North
Carolina.
Maybe there should be a different conversation
happening in each state.
It doesn't mean we don't have gun safety regulations
or that I think we shouldn't have them.
But it's at least plausible.
When it comes to abortion, it's fundamentally
about this is a medical procedure and this
is a procedure in which you shouldn't have
politicians in the middle.
Why is it better to have a local, you know,
a governor or a mayor?
Telling women what they can't do rather than
a senator in DC.
Either way, it's bad and this is a completely
outrageous and extreme position.
Here is just a clip.
Just to really sum up the difference in the
positions between Mehmet Oz and John Fetterman
on this issue.
Speaker 2: All I want women, doctors, local
political leaders letting the democracy that
always allowed our nation to thrive, to put
the best ideas forward so states can decide
for themselves.
Contrast that with my opponent, John Fetterman.
But if you believe that the choice for abortion
belongs between you and your doctor, that's
what I fight for.
Speaker 1: It's that.
That's.
It's that simple.
And Oz's position, of course, has been cobbled
together in trying to basically focus group
the best possible thing to say exceptions,
but not this and no federal involvement.
But let local verb.
It's a mess and it's outrageous and it's extreme.
The Fetterman position is the correct position.
Now, John Fetterman did comment on his stroke,
and he had the following to say about it.
Speaker 2: Sylvania Here's a man that spent
more than $20 million of his own money to
try to buy that seat.
I'm also having the talk about something called
the Oz Rule that if he's on TV, he's lying.
He did that during his career on his TV show.
He's done that during his campaign about lying
about our record here.
And he's also lying probably during this debate.
And let's also talk about the elephant in
the room.
I had a stroke.
He's never let me forget that.
And I might miss some words during this debate.
Two words together.
But it knocked me down.
But I'm going to keep coming back up.
And this campaign is all that to me is about
fighting for every one in Pennsylvania that
ever got knocked down that needs to get back
up and fighting for all forgotten communities
all across Pennsylvania that also got knocked
down.
That needs to keep solving.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So as you can see.
It takes a lot of courage to do what Fetterman
did last night.
It's he's in the middle of a recovery from
a stroke, and he brought it up and it was
really something to see and also quite difficult
to watch.
The issue of the quack cures promoted by Mehmet
Oz on his program came up yesterday and listen
very carefully to the exact language that
Oz uses, and you will very quickly see why
he's choosing such narrow language.
Mr. Oz, you have built a lucrative career
around medicine.
Speaker 2: But you've been criticized even
by some fellow physicians for promoting, quote,
unproven, ill advised and at times potentially
dangerous treatments.
What is your response to that?
You have 60 seconds and what did you or your
company make a profit from promoting those
products?
I never sold weight loss products as as described
in those commercials.
It's like it's a television show.
Like this is a television show so people can
run commercials on the shows.
And that's a perfectly appropriate and very
transparent process.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: I consider the language there.
I never sold weight loss products as described
in John Fetterman commercials.
Okay.
That is extraordinarily narrow language.
He provided a platform for those products.
It made the show profitable.
He was promoting green coffee extract as a
magical weight loss cure that is not evidence
based.
He was promoting raspberry ketones as the,
quote, number one miracle in a bottle to burn
your fat.
That is not evidence based.
He promoted guests who say homoeopathy works
uncritically.
And I know some people in my audience get
mad about this.
It doesn't work.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know people e-mail me every time.
There are no active ingredients in homeopathy.
There are no measurable, active ingredients.
It does not work.
It has been widely studied.
Oh, but David.
Big Pharma won't allow studies, guys.
Homeopathy has been widely studied.
It doesn't work and Oz promoted it.
So extraordinarily narrow language there.
Oz also promoting medication supposedly for
colds.
The way to get rid of a cold is to wait 5
to 7 days.
Okay.
No matter what you take during those 5 to
7 days.
Right.
Coffee enema, which is dangerous, by the way.
You know, fried plantains, um, baths with
whatever, you know, coconut oil.
About 5 to 7 days later, the cold will be
gone.
And to attribute it to all of these different
supposed cold cures doesn't actually make
any sense.
So bottom line, the question with this race
is what happens with the polling?
What happens with the polling at this point
in time?
Because going into yesterday's debate, the
polling is what it is right now.
Fetterman Plus 1.3.
And if you take a look, you will see that
Fetterman had a nearly nine point lead in
early August, and that lead was only six at
the beginning of September, and that lead
was only four towards the end of September,
and that lead is now 1.3.
How much of an impact can a single debate
have on a race like this, particularly when
one candidate is visibly struggling with his
speech as a result of the stroke that he had?
I don't have the answer, but we'll find out
in the next 7 to 10 days, and then the election's
only two weeks away and then we'll know
a lot more.